welcome back to the morning toast jackie
and i are
humbled honored and just like so excited
for our guests we have
all three cast mates we've got asia
we've got
katie we've got megan from the bowl type
you guys thank you
so much for being here we've been
talking about your show for the last two
weeks on the podcast we are
obsessed and now you're here final
seasons premiering in two days like
we're devastated
yeah yeah people people are pretty sad
about it well that leads me to my first
question why
[Laughter]
well free form i mean
questions no
no we weren't we weren't that's the
thing is like i think that it's really
cool that like
i've been on a show where we have been
canceled before it's the time
and we don't get to get the chance to
like wrap it up
and so i think i speak on behalf of the
three of us when i say like we are very
grateful
to freeform for giving us a season
letting us know it's the last one
letting the writers know its last ones
that they could like really
wrap up the stories and like give these
characters and us
the goodbyes that we wanted and deserve
yeah and you guys
you really five seasons is like so cool
no it's amazing and to be able to end on
your own terms is always ideal you know
but i think for some of us it's just
like upsetting
because like we have found comfort in
the show and in the development of your
characters but also the characters
around you like jaclyn and oliver
and i just like i don't know what i'm
gonna do without my gals
well you could re-watch the show now
benjamin already did
again finish filming the final season
yeah so how do you feel about the way it
ends for your powerpoint
do you feel do you feel good about it
i definitely do i think people are going
to be happy
we better with you we're you we
better i'll be so upset seriously
unforgivable if we don't see a sutton
and richard like i get that you have to
play with us in season four
but like obviously you guys are otp and
if that doesn't work out like just know
like i will
be upset wait what's otp i don't know
what that is
one true pairing i learned this recently
oh cool
and that's like what you guys are so i'm
glad to hear that yeah i agree
yeah what about you aisha how are we
feeling where cat ends up
i was actually very surprised i was not
expecting it
and it really happened so fast i was
like what
okay that's good to know i mean i feel
like the show is successful for so many
reasons
but for us like i feel two really strong
ways about the show one i think you guys
incorporate social media and just like
influencers
in a really natural way where sometimes
like you hear like tv shows like emily
and paris like talking about influencers
and it's like
so cringy you can die so i feel like it
actually makes us feel seen like
you guys actually like that is how it
actually is as an influencer
and i think you guys really handle like
controversial topics
in really approachable ways like one of
our favorite episodes was betsy the gun
like it was so funny
let's see my girl valuable i just think
yeah and like when you guys are filming
those episodes like do you guys know
like that it's gonna be it's like so
funny but it's also very accessible
talking about like
hard things i i think that we've always
you know there are some times where we
do something that's a controversial
topic and we're like
i hope that this goes over the way it's
intended
but i think we have always been able to
show the gray area to these topics to be
like
oh you can actually sit and disagree
about something and be able to have a
conversation about it
and you know come out the other side
maybe with
with more knowledge and feel more
educated about where somebody's coming
from and
you know i think that that's important
in this day and age where like so many
people
just want to live in an echo chamber and
don't want to challenge themselves to
like
think about how other people feel or
might feel differently
um so i feel like we've always handled
that and we have always gotten messages
from fans being like we paused the show
and like me and my friends talked about
it
and i think that that's like so cool to
have that effect
yeah it's super valuable and also like
another element that i just feel like
really elevates the show is the wardrobe
and jackie actually pointed something
out to me that i thought was so
interesting that like some of your
characters have worn
the same thing more than once which is
like how actual girls who work in a
magazine
live and just like normal people and so
first of all i love that in second well
do you get to keep any of your clothes
cause like they're all so stunning
we were able to buy some of them this
final season
um and we did that half off
which by the way for most of the stuff
that we wear is like still
a pretty penny like it's not
but that was like one of the cool things
about it it's like some of the stuff
that i took home like i would never
buy for myself so it just felt like a
good opportunity you know they like
tailor everything to our bodies and
stuff so why not
that's true and so where do i spill
montreal oh
[Music]
yeah so like the yeah the outdoor scenes
the outdoor scenes i mean in season one
we did get to go
to new york and like film for a couple
days but apart from that like there's a
park
in montreal that like we cheat as
central park
and that is so interesting
right i can tell because of the
scaffolding and i really miss it
literally they've been putting up the
scaffolding in front of our like
beautiful
excuse me our beautiful window and it's
like hello and there's like construction
usually during our show
you'll see like a bunch of hot
construction guides just like working on
i love it look at this dog
oh this is theo he's a huge fan he
watched the whole um series with me a
couple weeks ago and
he had some thoughts but overall he's
really pulling for sutton and richard so
hopefully you can make that work for him
for theo yeah theo okay yeah
on theo's behalf so the new season
premieres in two days how are we feeling
are we we're obviously sad we're you
know bittersweet but how are you guys
feeling about the final season
i'm excited i think it's great i think
people are going to like it
and sorry man we're all ready to kind of
like
give it to the world and then sort of
move
forward down the road yeah we're ready
did that change
all right well um yeah it changed it a
lot
but you know what's nice about it was
we knew what everyone's face looked like
you know
from their nostrils down because we've
been really blessed to have a lot of the
same crew
for all five seasons so i think it would
have been a lot harder if we didn't know
everyone already and have
like cultivated relationships with them
so we all kind of helped each other
through it but yeah it was really hard
like
you know that's part of the reason why i
love my job is
that i get to feel like i'm in the
circus and like talk to people
hug people and um so that that was
really difficult but you know we got
through it and i'm so
like i mean i speak for all of us but i
feel like we're all so grateful that we
got to do it because
um you know these are like interesting
times so
we're very blessed for sure we're
grateful that you got to do it because
we're so excited the new season
premieres
on freeform on the 26th of may so we'll
be watching
thank you guys so much for being here we
are obsessed like thank you for the work
that you do
for the culture for the community like
we love you
thank you guys and thank you guys for
listening we will see you tomorrow